[Applause]
oh you heard blake right
that's his wife gwen stefani shelton
married life sure looks good on blake
and gwen who took the stage together at
the cma summer jam in nashville
on tuesday gwen was blake's special
guest
and their duet happy anywhere did not
disappoint
[Applause]
the pair belted their track and sounded
fantastic
but fans couldn't help but notice how in
love they seem
check out the body language and the
strong eye contact
[Music]
[Applause]
blake kept it casual in his signature
jeans and a black
shirt while gwen hit the perfect balance
of country and rock and roll
in a white mini dress and coordinated
boots
the no doubt singer shared this image of
her fit to instagram
and called out her hubby in the caption
asking quote
blake shelton next time i get to wear a
pretty dress
will you take a picture with me the pair
may not have any instapix from the night
but
who needs pics when you've got footage
from your stellar duet
this isn't the first time the happy
couple has hit the stage since becoming
mr and mrs
earlier this month they played an
intimate show together at blake's bar
ulred in oklahoma gwen went deep into
the archives to sing no doubt's classic
don't speak with blake on the guitar
[Music]
but what really got fans talking was how
gwen reacted to blake introducing her
without her new last name beyonce
stefani's singing and tisha meena
[Music]
[Applause]
looks like blake heard his wife loud and
clear and made the correction
at the cma event
[Applause]
of course the pair tied the knot on july
3rd at the country star's oklahoma ranch
the intimate gathering was attended by
only their closest friends and family
and at the time a source opened up to
e.t about the picture-perfect wedding
quote they both have been through a lot
and deserve to find each other
they were meant to be a couple in every
[Music]
way
you